غضب واستياء في مدن روسيه ودعواتنا
لمعاقبه القاده العسكريين المسؤولين عن
مقتل المجندين في مكه الورود التي حملتها
اهالي الضحايا ووضعتها على ضريح الجندي
المجهول تحمل بقدر الحزن السيايا ومطالبه
باجابات عن موت كان من الممكن تفاديه
وخصوصا ان الاهالي يتهمون القيادات
العسكريه بالتقصير وعدم توفير الحمايه
اللازمه للمجندين خصوصا بعد قرار السماح
باستخدام الهواتف ما سهاما في تحديد
القوات الاوكرانيه لموقعهما مقابله مطالب
الاهالي يبرز وعيد سياسي وبرلماني يطالب
بمعقبه القاده العسكريين بتهمه تجاهل
المخاطر مدون عسكري روسي يتابعه اكثر من
700,000 شخص على تيليجرام وصف لاستهدافه
بالمروعه والقاب اللوم على قاده الجيش
الروسي
من الذي اتى بفكره وضع مجندين باعداد
كبيره في مبنى واحد في اي استهداف سيخلف
الكثير من القتل والجرحى يقول خبراء
عسكريون روز ان الهجوم الاوكراني الذي نفذ
في صواريخهم اسكباروسيا خساره هي الافدح
عسكريا ومعنويا خصوصا من ناحيه تاثير على
اقبال الشبان الروس على تجنيد اضافه الى
تعثر الحمله العسكريه التي اقتربت من
انهاء عامها الاول بدون اي انجازات تذكر